imagine dating like I've had the war
season I'm gonna give you I can only
give you like three right now but i can
write a book about David's 1001 worst
excuses on why not showing up to a date
one would be oh I'm sorry I can't go on
the date with you the day off the date
like look I'm getting deported to my
hard drive crash i'm getting my colon
cleanse like just
no one can create a viral video and
anyone that says to you that can make a
viral video it's going to be lighters
but you cannot reverse engineer a viral
video 72 hours of video uploaded to
YouTube every minute less than three
percent of videos upload to YouTube go
over 1,000 views hi my name is Dan
revoir and I'm an entertainer living in
Los Angeles I've been given seven
chances to create a viral video this is
my adventure and I invite you to come on
with me can I go viral can we tell you
what I all I do like Tara vogue anko
there we go that was awesome she's so
naughty she's so naughty yeah yeah oh
wow really a colon cleanse during like a
who cleans their colon like during the
week you know like who does a colon
cleanse during the week you know like
that's the thing do it on a weekend you
know like a Saturday Sunday because you
can stay home but like really come on
now it's always good to meet someone at
the location if you meet the for the
first time on a date always because what
if you get you you pick that person up
and they tend to not be the person you
don't they were going to be on this date
you know at least you can part separate
ways you're like okay cool but if you're
driving that person you like oh my gosh
like what did I just what end up just
happening like this is not gonna work
out um another good advice don't get
roses don't you know don't do that on
the first date dial creep somebody out
don't try to I guess get the first kiss
on the first date um yeah there's a lot
of good advice that I could for sure no
you know like oh I think nowadays
everybody kind of go half and half on a
bill dating but I don't know why I think
I think it's always guys the guy should
always pay on the first day you know um
that's how i feel i mean i think that
just and then the second day maybe she's
like okay cool let's just split it but
the first did I think should definitely
do that guy should always do that for
women which cool debt for women to show
I like those pics like sexy pics you
know like oh my gosh like nudie pics i
think those those are cute cuz it's kind
of like or like a little bits of the
same message maybe like a little set
like a bra or some like that' but that's
when you start to get you another person
but men I'm gonna tell you this dick
pics don't work like girls are not gonna
get excited over a dick like honestly
that's the worst thing ever like it's
just the word anybody who says them i
mean people who send them and the disk
image people just report them they just
get reported for sexual harassment you
don't want what the like it looks like a
gremlin or a tremor or some type of like
heart like it's not cute it's not sexy
so it's like that's something you got to
enjoy the privacy of your own home just
guys just don't think like a girl's
gonna see a dick pic of like oh my gosh
hold up brenda i gotta leave work early
cuz look at this just came in I gotta go
like it dick pics don't worry guys and
just letting you know cuz I be who said
them but they just don't it's not cool
you know just it's not sexy just one
that you know that's not sexy only girls
can pull that off join me David war for
the next episode of can I go viral well
I will soon attempt to make a viral
YouTube video